[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours retenus à distancer nos
reporters voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 15 juillet
est notre première ambition ressouder la
nation jean castex a prononcé sa
déclaration de politique générale devant
les députés cette après midi
elle vient d'être adopté à une large
majorité avec 345 voix le chômage
priorité absolue des 18 prochains mois
décentraliser davantage lutter contre
les séparatismes le premier ministre a
précisé la feuille de route sur les 600
prochains jours autour des nombreux
thèmes abordés hier par le président de
la république
ces actes odieux ne doivent pas rester
impunis réaction de gérald darmanin près
qu'un pompier a été blessé par balle
hier soir à étampes alors qu'ils
intervenaient sur un feu dans le
quartier de guinette le ministre de
l'intérieur qui annonce que toute
agression de sapeurs-pompiers débouchera
systématiquement sur une plainte
donald trump annonce la fin du régime
économiques préférentielles accordées
par les états unis à hong kong le
président américain qui a également
signé une loi prévoyant des sanctions
contre la répression dans le territoire
chinois
après le vote de la loi sur l'accès
curité nationale promulguée le 30 juin
cette loi prévoit de nouveaux pouvoirs
judiciaires dans l'ancienne colonie
britannique la chine elle menace les
etats-unis de représailles
[Musique]
un peu plus d'une heure de discours de
politique générale pour jean castex à
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi
texte qui vient tout juste d'être
adoptée à une large majorité avec 345
voix des députés objectif proposer une
méthode pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique voulue par le président de la
république plan de relance économique
écologie d'essence réalisation aide aux
étudiants ou encore lutte contre les
séparatismes à l'école de nombreuses
annonces ont été faites par le premier
ministre les précisions de kate ci a
conclu jean castex souhaite une nouvelle
méthode pour prendre la crise à bras le
corps et en préambule de son discours
d'une heure il a souhaité réunir la
france une france divisée
les différentes france qui composent
notre pays en tant qu homme de terrain
il apprenait le dialogue social il
faisait évidemment référence aux
syndicats qu'il a déjà rencontré
d'ailleurs il évoquera prochainement
avec la réforme des retraites alors
concernant cette écoute cette ouverture
je vous propose de l'écouter il y a
beaucoup de france qui se sentent loin
et laissé pour compte
france des banlieues france rurale
france d outre-mer france dit
périphériques france de ceux y compris
au coeur de nos villes n'ont pas droit à
la parole
c'est france là son autre pays autant
que la phrase de la réussite économique
scientifique industriel ou culturels
dont nous sommes légitimement fiers et
ce sera notre première ambition immense
réconcilier ces france si différentes
les souder ou les ressouder
il a beaucoup insisté sur la
décentralisation qui souhaite accentuer
il veut doter massivement les
territoires et il souhaite aussi une loi
de différenciation à la clé pour
davantage d'autonomie davantage
d'initiatives des territoires et puis il
a détaillé des contours seulement ce
n'était pas forcément très précis mais
d'un plan de relance économique
écologique doté de 100 milliards
seulement 20 milliards pour l'écologie
40 milliards pour les industries pour
davantage de souveraineté nationale ans
dans le domaine et puis bien sûr
priorité à la lutte contre le chômage
priorité à l'emploi à la formation je
vous propose de l'écouter
c'est donc avec une méthode nouvelle que
nous allons prendre ensemble à bras le
corps cette crise avec une obsession en
tête la lutte contre le chômage
hamou sur l'aspect sécuritaire il
prévoit d'ici 2021 sur les territoires
des juges d'instruction pour combattre
les sensibilités
au quotidien ils souhaitent combattre
également l'islamisme radical promouvoir
la laïcité
il a eu des mots d'encouragement pour
les forces de l'ordre et puis il prévoit
un projet de loi contre les séparatismes
pour que certains groupes ne s'enferme
pas dans des appartenances ethniques ou
religieuses on se souvient que c'était
un un projet défendu par emmanuel macron
il ya quelques mois
alors évidemment vous imaginez
l'ambiance des députés aujourd'hui qui
critique qui estime qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un changement de cap amorcé par jean
castex mais plutôt d'une continuité de
la politique d' emmanuel macron et un
discours qui a fait réagir les députés
d'opposition regardez écoutez c'était
aussi long ennuyeux
bourré de clichés que prévu il ya une
seule chose satisfaisante puisque ça
nous donne raison c'est une victoire
idéologique c'est le retour de la au
commissariat au plan
voilà maintenant il va falloir qu'elle
compte lui donne mais au moins ils
admettent ce que nous disons depuis deux
ans et demi on le reste c'était un long
résumé de poncifs de clichés libéraux et
sécuritaire que je retiens de ce
discours c'est de l'empathie ce que je
retiens c'est de faire cette france qui
est fracturé la france des territoires
la province qui est presque de un gros
mot à paris ce que je retiens c'est que
le politique reprenne sa place et
qu'effectivement au bout de trois ans va
changer de braquet
cette volonté elle est naturellement
scène elle est même indispensable mais
pour valoriser les territoires il faut
des actes on peut pas nous resservir
pour la 44e fois le développement du
haut débit ou de la téléphonie mobile ou
le maintien des petites ligues ça nous
l'attendions
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière quelles
mesures concrètes
quel souffle quelles ambitions de
décentralisation je suis resté sur ma
faim
le compte à rebours a donc débuté pour
le premier ministre et son gouvernement
dès 6 ans vous relancer dans leurs
stocks us reconstruction du pays pour en
parler
nous sommes en direct avec lexie poulain
cofondateur du média le monde bonnaire
dont soir alexis poulain merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés pour décrypter en
ce discours de jean castex ludovic de
l'air spécialiste en communication
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france peut-être
une première impression justement sur la
forme vous le spécialiste de la
communication ludovic de la r je vous
l'avais trouvé plutôt bon jean castex je
lui trouvais castex à sakina un peu
raide quand même et puis on a quand même
un bon padawan de la novlangue dire qu
on a eu quelques expressions qui ne
voulaient strictement rien dire
notamment les députés parler des
territoires quand il parle à nouveau de
libérer les énergies
on a retrouvé du maquereau
mais ont un peu moins trop luc et alexis
poulain votre avis en tout cas
premièrement sur la forme
voilà un nouveau genre en tout cas qui
tranche avec celui d'edouard philippe
oui enfin on fait du neuf avec du vieux
j'ai envie de dire et on a l'impression
que jean castex s'amuse découvre ce pays
prend son temps et va jouer en fait le
bon flic en fait atteint c'est un peu un
duo qui va se mettre en place pour
préparer la candidature pour 2022 des
modèles macron parce qu'il est entré en
campagne et jean castex va être le bon
flic celui qui va parler aux territoires
quand emmanuel macron n'a pas du tout
réussi et bien à recoller les morceaux à
éviter les divisions de cette france
qu'il n'a fait que diviser depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir donc c'est cette figure
là un peu rondes un peu complètement
transparente qui va permettre au
président de dérouler son programme
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs aucun
changement de cap on reprend les idées
de la campagne de 2017
on va essayer de les mettre à la sauce
2020 pour en faire un programme un
projet de campagne sans savoir vraiment
ce qu'on va faire en six ans jours avec
moi ce qui me fait peur c'est de voir
ces gens là en charge du pays
partant de grosses tempêtes avec une
crise économique une crise sociale sans
précédent qui arrive devant nous une
crise sanitaire qui n'est pas fini on
les a vus au coeur de la crise sanitaire
il était nul on va les voir pour ce qui
est de la crise sociale et la crise
économique qui arrive
j'ai peur qu'avec les vieilles recettes
proposées par jean castex et les
milliards qui vont être dépensées peu
importe comment le plan va fonctionner
eh bien ça ne suffisent pas parce que là
on a tout simplement et bien un discours
de communication
davantage qu'un discours d'action et de
volontariat de volontarisme c'est ce qui
manque depuis le début d'ailleurs à ce
quinquennat c'est un quinquennat de la
com et et jean castex naine etc n'est là
que pour faire de la com pour être cet
homme des territoires cet homme est bien
dû delà de la synthèse à une sorte de
françois hollande du maquereau nisme
ludovic de la rh vous vous partagez ce
diagnostic assez sévère d'alexis poulain
uniquement de la com et est moins
d'action c'est vrai qu'il s'agit plus de
territoire jusqu'à dans l'accent alors
on en a beaucoup parlé ça ne veut pas
dire grand chose mais c'est vrai jusqu'à
dans l'action du premier ministre on est
davantage dans la proche des régions
parlera du tournant social après mai
mais bon vous vous n'y croyez pas ce
changement de méthode vous lui
d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron est
incarnée par le premier ministre ben si
je devais y croire je serai peut-être le
seul en france ainsi concrètement enfin
en tout cas des gens qui réfléchissent
et pas ceux qui suivent le gourou
suprême mais j'ai pas tout à fait
d'accord avec alexis poulain en réalité
je pense que jean castex n'avait pas
être temps que ça une figure ronde
il va être aussi une figure assez
implacable sur les retraites qui va
mener au pas de charge
alors effectivement avec un accent
chantant ceseda technique des
monochromes depuis le départ on est sans
le sou poudrage de micro communautés en
permanence donc oui là je suis d'accord
avec alexis il va cibler les territoires
et jean castex il nous construit un peu
comme un pagnol même s'il n'est pas de
la provence et c'est encore une image
d'épinal qu'on nous sert évidemment mais
par contre il va être raide sur toutes
les mesures qui doit mettre en place sur
notamment la réforme des retraites
et je pense qu'il sera même assez
violent et on aura là pas du tout quand
on parle de changement de braquet
certains députés parler de ça je pense
que ça va dans le mauvais sens et que
même si jean castex dans sa carrière il
faut lui reconnaître comme une grande
compétence et savoir vivre d'argent
public
donc pour ça il est bien dans la macro
ni mais par contre il faut lui
reconnaître autre chose c'est que autour
du d'une élection qu'il avait dans le
sport effectivement il a réussi à faire
parler des gens entre eux et d'être en
permanence dans l'apparence de
consultation donc c'est ce qu'il est en
train de faire en ce qui est en train de
faire et les syndicats effectivement
dont qui les fait venir pour faire
croire qu'ils leur parle mais ils sont
tous partis en claquant la porte
donc ça n'a pas marché et puis on va
avoir oui ces deux figures qu'il va être
là qui est
vous savez je crois que la présence de
jean castex et est révélateur d'une
grande crise analysé pendant le
confinement je pense qu'il ya eu une
énorme crise et que nemo ne rapporter
plus la balle à son pépère et du coup il
fallait un nouveau pour pouvoir amusé
emmanuel macron parce que c'est
totalement un homme de paille il ne
décide de rien tout est la politique que
veut emmanuel macron politique constate
qu'elle maniait rubrique on mette en
place ce qui vont financer et
encadrement la politique sur laquelle il
a fait campagne et jean castex va
appliquer la feuille de route souhaité
par emmanuel macron emmanuel lacroix a
compté 8 de ce côté et là je rejoins
hier alexis sur l'idée du duo
vaslui de son côté jouer la fibre
sociale de la contrition tandis que jean
castex à faire le sale boulot
il a l'habitude l'habitude de le faire
c'est un haut fonctionnaire il a
l'habitude de s'y coller et il va le
faire
la fibre sociale vous l'avez dit
certains observateurs alors pas vous aux
messieurs manifestement certains
observateurs ont pu voir un tournant
social mais premier ministre cet après
midi parmi les mesures justement sociale
je vous propose d'écouter celles ci un
euro a justement pour les étudiants en
oeuvre au un repas fixé à 1 euro pour
les étudiants boursiers écouter parce
qu'ils sont l'avenir ce sont les jeunes
sept cent mille d'entre eux vont bientôt
se présenter sur le marché du travail
aucun d'entre eux ne doit se trouver
sans solution des mesures très fortes
ont d'ores et déjà été annoncées pour
soutenir l'apprentissage
il faut aller plus loin m un plan pour
la jeunesse sera discuté vendredi avec
les partenaires sociaux
premier impératif favoriser l'embauché
les tailles et de rares comme l'a
annoncé le chef de l'état avec un
dispositif exceptionnel de réduction du
coût du travail à hauteur de 4000 euros
par an pour les jeunes de moins de 25
ans jusqu'à 1,6 smic
dans toutes les entreprises et pour une
durée d'au moins un an
deuxième impératif lutter contre le
décrochage durable des jeunes qui sont
les plus éloignés de l'emploi
trois cent mille parcours et contrat
d'insertion permettront d'aller toucher
les jeunes les plus en difficulté et
5000 places de plus un service civique
troisième impératif troisième impératif
soutenir les étudiants notamment les
plus modestes qui se retrouvent en
difficulté avec moins d'accès aux petits
boulots dès la rentrée les repas dans
les restaurants universitaires seront à
1 euro pour les étudiants boursiers
n'ont alors pas donc un euro c'est et à
la fin on voit qu'il ya pas mal de
mesures prévues pour les étudiants
alexis poulain on ne peut pas parler de
tournant social tout de même vous
n'accorder aucun crédit à ces mesures
annoncées enfin c'est pas des mesures
sociales du tout on a affaire là à un
accompagnement de crise profonde mais
avec des mesures qui rappelle en fait le
cicr
ce cadeau ce que vos entreprises l'idée
c'est de faire des cadeaux des promesses
de campagne de pré campagne là il l'a
dit d'ailleurs c'est un dispositif qui
va durer un an
ah bah ça tombe bien puisque après on va
commencer la campagne présidentielle
c'est pour maquiller les chiffres du
chômage qui vont être massif
mais si vous regardez les recettes
proposées par jean castex et quoi c'est
dire aux gens de travailler plus et en
même temps et bien essayé d'intégrer des
jeunes qui vont entrer dans l'âge du
travail en fait un truc très simple
évidemment oui il faut mettre le paquet
sur l'apprentissage il faut mettre le
paquet sur l'entrée dans le monde du
travail parce que ça se rattrape pas
après mai mais le logiciel et même on
veut faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps plutôt que partager le temps
de travail pour que ces jeunes trouvent
immédiatement de travail et puis les
repas un euro c'est quoi c'est une
aumône parce que par derrière la
mentalité de ce gouvernement c'est est
de baisser les apl c'est de rendre
compliqué la vie
je me rappelle j'ai une pensée pour ce
jeune qui s'était immolé par le feu
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à vivre ce
jeune étudiant qui n'arrivait pas réussi
avec 7 devant son crous il ya le
problème du logement étudiant qui est
fondamental qui
pas du tout abordé qu'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui qu'on n'y arrive pas c'est
parce que le logement coûte trop cher
c'est parce que les transports coûtent
trop cher est ce qu'il ya des mesures
qui sont faits qui vont dans ce sens là
non on va faire des repas au resto u 1
euro ce n'est pas assez l'aplomb passa
du social c'est simplement des mesures
qui vont aider les entreprises à et bien
profiter de mesures d'allègement pour
embaucher pendant un an pour que les
chiffres du chômage dans un an un an
bien soit présentable et comme dalmat
qu'on puisse féliciter de son bilan
fictif c'est à peu près tout ce qui est
présenté ici malheureusement j'attendais
beaucoup plus pas dans l'ue de vie que
de l'air chaud rajustement ce tournant
social on rappelle aussi qu'à une
revalorisation de 100 euros de façon
exceptionnelle de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire c'est quand même
beaucoup d'argent qu'on sort encore et
la dette qui se creuse votre réaction
sur toutes ces mesures bâle c'est de
l'argent qu'on sort effectivement donc
on sort de l'argent on va sortir deux
points du pib
les allemands en sorte 20 pour sortir de
la crise voilà à peu près ce que ça
donne la gestion de crise en france je
dis pas que les allemands raison en tout
cas c'est assez étrange comme comme
grand écart ensuite je partage l'avis
d'alexis tout en n'étant pas tout à fait
d'accord sûr que y'a pas il n'y a pas
que des cadeaux d'entreprise les 4000
euros par les chante
ben oui en fait c'est l'argent public
encore qu'on donne aux entreprises ça
qu'on financer des emplois et il ya
quand même sur ce le repas des étudiants
une problématique qui est assez
importante effectivement les étudiants
peuvent pas se nourrir donc c'est une
bonne mesure on voit qu'elle ne dure
qu'un an c'est une honte mais c'est une
bonne mesure
par contre il aurait fallu gommer des
problèmes parcours c'est parce que vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui pourront ne
semble pas manger qui seront pas non
plus étudiants parce qu'ils sont
inscrits nulle part et qui sont perdus
dans les méandres de parcours sub quitte
un four absolue et stéphanie pour
revenir sur votre réflexion de l'argent
qu'on sort on sorte 200000 euros par
mois pour une application de ce top
coville qui ne sert à rien dans lequel
il ya vingt mille abonnés enfin va mais
inscrit imaginez deux cent mille euros
par mois d'entretien de cette
application qui ne sert à rien donc
l'argent on sait le sortir regardez les
milliards qu'on a donné à des
entreprises airbus air france pendant la
crise alors qu'on n'a pas de regret pour
les étudiants n'ont donc l'argent c'est
un petit con si si je peux me permettre
les devis que de l'air chaud on ne donne
à ces entreprises parce qu'on
espère sauver quand même des emplois en
tout cas j'espère que c'est l'arrière
pensée très clairement affichée par le
gouvernement tout de même d'accord je
suis bien obligé pas être d'accord avec
moi sinon je n'ai pas mal et donc voilà
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce type
non mais j'aimerais relm avant en fait
on peut donner de l'argent aux
entreprises mais il faut que des paroles
licenciés derrière la haie l'endroit
licenciés donc donc donc ça ne tient pas
la problématique en fait c'est que où je
ne suis pas d'accord avec alexis c'est
qu'effectivement ça n'est pas que la
construction d'une campagne eux mêmes
macro ont l'habitude de faire financer
ses campagnes temps l'argent public il a
déjà déjà fait une fois quand il était
ministre de l'économie
mais là il n'y a pas que ça il ya aussi
d'aller dissoudre les républicains donc
il n'y a pas que entre guillemets un
volet social il ya aussi d'aller tenter
les républicains d'un côté leur prendre
un certain nombre d'éléments et de
déclencher des débats chez eux pendant
qu'il va se balade aux tuileries avec
madame donc vous voyez c'est beau c'est
plus complexe que ça et effectivement je
pense qu'il y aura certainement des
vraies mesures sociales importantes
nécessaires il a écouté un certain
nombre de choses il a pris ce qui
l'arrangeait pour préparer ou une
élection c'est vrai donc on aura des
mesures sociales pendant un an ou deux
il ya une telle casse pendant trois ans
il faut déclencher beaucoup plus que ça
alexis paulin sur la délinquance la
sécurité le séparatisme et sa mise là je
mets tous dans le même panier il ya eu
plusieurs annonces aussi et leur
concernant les incivilités on va prendre
les choses dans l'ordre juge de
proximité ans est l'une des des annonces
autre annonce cette fois ci sur le
séparatisme un projet de loi est attendu
tout ça c'est du colmatage
selon vous non mais c'est cocasse jean
castex rappelons le était quand même le
secrétaire général adjoint à l'elysée
sous nicolas sarkozy c'est donc un
sarkozyste qui utilise ces méthodes
et puis il faut rappeler que nicolas
sarkozy est quand même le grand casseurs
de la police de proximité qui fait qu'on
en est là aujourd'hui aussi delà de la
façon dont le lien s'est rompu entre les
populations et les policiers donc oui il
essaye de recoller les morceaux après
avoir fait des mauvaises politiques
et puis qu'est-ce qu'il fait bien il
fait comme son mentor nicolas sarkozy
c'est-à-dire pour faire croire qu'il
agit et bien il à vendre des nouvelles
lois qui ne sont jamais appliquées ou
qui ne servent à rien pourquoi faire une
loi sur le séparatisme
quand les lois de la république existent
sont évidentes et fonctionne simplement
pour dire qu'on va et bien faire une loi
contre le séparatisme parce que c'est là
encore une fois un des thèmes de
campagne qui est en train de se mettre
en place pour 2022
on va agiter l'axé sécuritaire la
division et puis faire croire que les
lois actuelles ne fonctionne pas que la
laïcité telle qu'elle est présentée ne
marche pas alors qu'elle fonctionne
alors que les lois fonctionnent
c'est la preuve une fois encore de
vraiment l'impuissance politique
actuelle et c'est pas seulement emmanuel
macron je crois que ça remonte comme je
le disais à nicolas sarkozy l'agitation
législatif qui permet d'exister sur le
plan médiatique davantage que sur le
plan réel parce qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui manque en fait pour lutter contre
les séparatismes s'ils veulent les
appeler comme ça c'est des moyens des
moyens pour leur enseignement des moyens
pour la police et une véritable volonté
politique
eh bien je vois dans le discours de jean
castex que les moyens ne seront pas là
et que la volonté politique est bien
elle est transformée simplement en une
énième flambée législatives qui n'ira
nulle part
ludovic à de la recherche sur ce sujet
vous savez en sortie crise chez pas si
ces séparatistes ont d'islamisme radical
qui est l'urgence quand pas une seule
fois le mot femme n'a été prononcé par
jean castex pas une seule fois violence
pas une seule fois c'était violences
faites aux femmes sont passées sous le
tapis sous lequel se cache d'armes
maintenant ça par contre c'est
gravissime sûr que s'il ya bien une
chose qui s'est passée par deux choses
qui sont passées pendant ces épisodes du
duc o vie du confinement
c'est l'évidence cette femme est la
situation précarité des gens dans la rue
pas un seul mot là dessus par jean
castex sur la sortie de crise ça c'est
absolument aberrant l'égalité salariale
complètement oublié l'un c'était quand
même la priorité du quinquennat les
maquereaux enfin l'une des multiples
priorité mais s'était affichée comme la
priorité du quinquennat
pas un mot pas un seul mot vous imaginez
ce tir que je comprends qu'il soit gêné
au retour aux entournures avec son
discours au mas hommes avec darmanin qui
a encore une fois reconnu avoir demandé
une fellation pour un service rendu il
avoir utilisé son pouvoir pour ça il est
midi à l'intérieur donc sans trop de
gêne aux entournures
mais là s'il ya bien un sujet sur lequel
on peut avoir une sortie de crise qui
nous aurait été honorable et surtout
nécessaire
c'est travailler sur l'égalité salariale
évidence cette femme rien rien toujours
pas dit s est donc les assauts
continuent à crever parce que il n'ya
pas de défiscalisation voyez le volet
social en réalité et ses angles de
sécuritaires sont aussi de la poudre aux
yeux ou surtout la façon de tirer un
débat dans un sens qui va les arranger
pour plus tard parce que le bilan de la
macro ni catastrophique absolument ça
c'est certain
moi ce que je ne comprends pas et je
vous pose la question ouvertement c'est
que va [ __ ] à républicains là dedans
que pourquoi castex va faire ça dans
quand il joue au premier ministre mais
j'imagine que que c'est gratifiant et
glorifiant et d'être heureux mais je ne
comprends pas comment est ce que les
républicains il va se dissoudre à ce
point et aller à la soupe alors que le
bilan est tellement catastrophique même
si c'est une politique de droite qui
menait depuis le départ et d'aller à la
suite d loire philippe et il ya un des
députés aujourd'hui qui le dit assez
brillamment jean castex est condamné à
faire moins bien qui emmanuel macron
parce que s'il fait mieux
il va servir et et faire moins bien la
marge de manoeuvre reste très faible
alexis me collard votre votre réponse
justement vous vous poser les mêmes
questions que les victoires
oui je crois qu'il ya une déliquescence
morale intellectuelle
une faillite vraiment des élites comme
les appelle jean castex républicaine
quand on voit la composition de ce
gouvernement avec le président de la
république qui disait de faire les bons
choix et choisir les meilleurs on est en
droit de se poser des questions en fait
sur la dégringolade en fait du personnel
politique aujourd'hui en france alors
que d'autres personnes existent sont
bien bien plus compétente et il n'y
avait pas à choisir un darmanin pour
être ministre de l'intérieur d'y aller
dans ce gouvernement dont les personnes
lors je pense justement que les gens les
gens aujourd'hui qui travaille avec
emmanuel macron se compromettent en sont
tout à fait conscients à la fois parce
que il ya eu toutes ces violences parce
qu'il ya tous ces échecs politiques et
ils vont simplement là parce que c'est
une façon d'exister mais regardez la
façon dont a été créée la république en
marche c'est un parti qui a du mal à
s'ancrer dans les territoires puisqu'ils
la claque aux municipales fait que ce
parti a fait pschitt et qui au niveau
parisien est un parti de court en fait
où eminem la con à l'époque recruté avec
l'ancien monsieur retraites a fait un
casting en fait de personnalités issues
de la droite et de la gauche mais qui
n'avait pas eu leur chance dans leurs
partis respectifs donc on a affaire à
des à des ambitieux à des arrivistes et
à des traîtres
ça fait un parti qui bat qui fait une
politique de cet acabit malheureusement
justement les territoires on en a parlé
en début de ce décryptage c'était
vraiment voilà le mot qui revenait les
territoires le local ressouder également
la france notre première ambition sur ce
point là pas de bénéfice du doute
accordée au premier ministre lui de vie
que de la recherche c'est un bon
diagnostic quand même de voir que
finalement tout le monde et est divisée
d'ailleurs ça a été assez applaudi dans
l'hémicycle cette partie du discours
oui enfin vous savez les députés en
marche lève le bras aussi bien qu'ils
applaudissent facilement mais concernant
les territoires vous savez avoir moi je
vous en parlais je parle de toute la
journée que la municipalité de mon
village de 280 habitants et sincèrement
le mal qui a été fait depuis trois ans
est catastrophique ça quand tout
l'argent qui a été coupée des
territoires c'est vraiment pharaonique
et aujourd'hui tout le monde survit
comme il peut en est mais vraiment il ya
des écoles qui ferment c'est très très
très compliqué donc oui c'est un sujet
c'est indéniable par contre ben en fait
il rien eu d'annoncé en réalité cercle
on a des offres à on verra c'est
important comme on a l'habitude depuis
cinq ans donc le depuis trois ans par
dont on parle depuis plus d'ailleurs
mais donc oui moi je suis prêt à y
croire ok je suis prêt à y croire sauf
que si on regarde ce qui a été fait
depuis trois ans à chaque fois qu'il ya
eu des annonces de ce type
ça n'a jamais été tenu au nom jean
castex ne n'est pas selon l'article
devant la constitution celui qui
détermine la politique du gouvernement
c'est pas vrai c'est emmanuel macron et
depuis trois ans il fait des fausses
promesses et dans les territoires c'est
pièce et pas un mot
en réalité c'est vraiment du quotidien
de secrétaire de mairie qui n'existe
plus et quand une mairie n'a plus de
secrétaire mais c'est sûr que c'est
assez compliqué une liste municipale et
comme des gens qui travaillent qui reste
tout les soirs jusqu'à minuit mois dans
la mairie c'est le cas le même petit but
municipalité parce qu'ils font double
travail pour essayer de colmater les
brèches de partout parce que il ya plus
d'argent
les associations et les associations qui
étaient des relais n'existe plus non
plus vraiment la notion de territoire
est plus que cruciale parce qu'il ya des
gens qui met littéralement il ya des
gens qui crèvent d'exploitation tous les
jours qui ferme merci à tous les deux en
tout cas alexis poule un lieu de vie de
l'air d'avoir été avec moi pour ce
cryptage en direct sur rt france est
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de ce sapeur pompier blessé
par un tir d'armes à feu lors d'une
intervention est en pleine nuit dernière
les syndicats dénoncent je cite un
guet-apens et puis direction hong kong
le bras de fer entre washington et pékin
se poursuit
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr la banque ne gagne
pas d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche deux mois de non
consommation mondiale et les plus gros
groupe s'arrête et 10 on n'a pas de
trésorerie
c'est un modèle assez extraordinaire un
la banque c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était privatisation des
gains et mutualisation des perfs donc en
fait c'est fâcheux gagne pile tu perds
ont créé une économie qui l'a zéro
valeur
statistiquement vous aurez une banque en
europe une banque majeur en europe 10 au
cra
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rtl france 20h30
heure de paris les soldats du feu en
première ligne pour sauver des vies est
confronté à tous les dangers mardi soir
à étampes
un sapeur pompiers en intervention a été
touché par un tir d'armes à feu une
nouvelle agression sur le terrain qui
augmente leur exaspération sur les
conditions de travail
retour sur une colère qui monte en
images
[Musique]
pour
oui
où
vous
[Musique]
m
mais
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
yannick athénée zee président du
syndicat national des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels bonsoir yannick télésites
merci d'être avec nous on vient de le
voir sur ces images le nombre
d'agressions sur votre profession à les
sapeurs pompiers n'a fait qu'augmenter
ces dernières années quel est votre état
d'esprit ce soir deux jours après cette
nouvelle attaque envers les soldats du
feu et amp
bonsoir merci merci de m'inviter dans
votre émission
écoutez notre état d'esprit les
désespérés parce que nous venons de
franchir encore un cap ce n'était pas la
première fois que les sapeurs pompiers
se faisait tirer dessus mais c'était
parfois sur leurs véhicules ou à côté
hélas un sapeur pompier a été touché par
une arme d'armes à feu ont franchi un
cap
je suis désolé de dire que les discours
des politiques
nous en avons assez ils nous doivent la
protection du style jean 40 ans du
norman en angleterre tout à l'heure mais
dans les faits il n'y a pas de
protection parce qu'il n'y a pas de
services de police pour pouvoir le faire
donc c'est vraiment plus que désespérant
les sapeurs-pompiers sont à bout et
réfléchissent à des solutions au quasi
il légal pour pour se mettre à l'abri
comment vous vous expliquer cette
augmentation des agressions dit autant
que les populaires les pompiers sont
parmi les professions les plus
populaires en france on a du mal à se
l'expliquer le métier de sapeur pompier
est le plus populaire de france parce
que l'immense majorité des français ça
parce que ce qu'ils doivent aux sapeurs
pompiers et à tous les services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
en revanche là on a affaire à des
délinquants à des criminels puisque
mettre le feu à des poubelles le mettre
le feu à des nos calculs belle à des
voitures c'est un délit tirer sur sa
part conclu moyen d'une arme à feu
c'est pas cris est en fait ce sont des
gens qui sont exclues complètement de la
société française de par leur
comportement
mais qui n'est pas propre à ce qu'il
puisse faire aux sapeurs pompiers ils
ont le même comportement avec des gens
qui y pénètre dans leur territoire que
ce soit le facteur que ce soit le
livreur d'amazon que ce soit le médecin
que ce soit n'importe qui en fait
quelqu'un qui est étranger à leur
territoire et c'est une
c'est un prétexte pour pour agresser
pour s'amuser puisque comme moi je vois
même pas ça comme défense du territoire
donc plus commune a la luz mans vous
êtes vous représentez l'état pour eux ou
c'est même plus bête que ça séjour se
dire à travers à travers vous c'est
l'état qu'on attaque d'une certaine
manière
certains veulent va la voir cette excuse
et je peux je peux prêter cette excuse
entre guillemets à certains qui n'est
pas pour autant quelque chose
d'acceptable mais pour moi effectivement
c'est plus quelque chose de bêtes c'est
vraiment on sait pas quoi faire maintien
on a eu un feu de poubelle
et puis bah premier client callas aussi
c'est la police basque accueille 6 et
les pompiers si les pompiers et puis
parfois plutôt que qaézé tiens on va
voir jean guy ligier j'ai touché une
nouvelle de longs échanges du tcb et un
sapeur pompier touché au mollet comment
clairement interviennent ces agressions
lorsqu'on vous êtes en intervention vous
venez d'en parler un petit peu
voilà on tire on envoie des caillasses
et c'est comme ça que ça se passe
clairement oui à lorient vous avez le
prétexte du 14 juillet comme comme
d'autres événements nationaux tels que
le 31 décembre la nuit de la saint
sylvestre
on a souvent affaire à des gens qui
veulent un record de cette poubelle une
faute voiture ou de feux d'artifices et
donc on envoie les mortiers sur les
pompiers que sur les policiers là le 14
juillet c'était un autre prétexte comme
un comme un autre effectivement dans ce
genre de événement festif c'est comme ça
que ça se passe où ou créer plusieurs
petits feux à leur sens aux mots chat et
à la souris avec la police et les
pompiers
il n'y a pas d' agression mais c'est un
jeu quand même dû collectionner du
nombre de feux dans le quartier
ou alors ou alors maintien on va se
faire on va sur un papier où je suis
policier ce coup-ci ou à les attendre et
on va s'y mettre à plusieurs pour le
calaisis c'est exactement comme ça que
ça se passe un guet-apens
mais ni les sapeurs pompiers ni la
police n'ont de comportement qui vise à
à provoquer la population locale
donc je sais c'est clairement ce sont
clairement des guet-apens et
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui clairement pardonnez moi
qu'on me réponde à ces à ces agressions
qui augmente quelles sont vos
revendications quelle est la solution
la solution ce n'est pas que
sapeur-pompier qui là ne nous sommes des
victimes
c'est à la société civile de trouver
cette solution mois lorsque j'entends le
de nos ministres lorsque j'entends les
préfets tout le monde se mobilise et la
presse à chaque fois qu'un événement de
ce genre comme vous le faites
aujourd'hui on vous en remercie
d'attirer l'attention du public sur sur
ces phénomènes mais à chaque fois entré
on demande à ce que les sapeurs pompiers
puissent avoir une intervention
sécurisée par les forces de sécurité
publique c'est pas un pompier de faire
sa propre sécurité
le pompier il a déjà sans sécurité à
penser le cadre d'un feu de désir
attention que je me blesse pas que je
sauve les gens que d'autres personnes ne
soient pas blessés
s'ils commencent à devoir penser en q ce
qu'il faut ne pas prendre une balle un
coup de couteau ou un caillou on va pas
être bien on demande tout simplement
parce que les services de l'état puisse
assurer notre sécurité en intervention
et pour ça il faut des moyens des moyens
policiers quand j'entendais décoller
dire pourquoi pas des gilets pare-balles
non on a autre chose à faire que de
mettre des gilets pare-balles on l'aimé
déjà ce rapt le terrorisme parce que
c'est vraiment un contexte particulier
mais pâte à modeler gilet pare balles
pour aller au feu qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire des gens
techniquement c'est pas possible
la police systématiquement oui dans les
cartes le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé avoir déposé plainte 1 et a
réaffirmé en soutien indéfectible à
votre profession sapeurs pompiers est ce
que c'est suffisant c'est ce que vous
attendez du
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur une
plainte systématique
écoutez ont remis un ordre inversé
ministre de l'intérieur d'avoir pris des
nouvelles de collègues qui s'est déplacé
au froid des collègues des temps c'est
important de montrer l'attachement de la
république pourquoi des sapeurs pompiers
maintenant on ne veut pas que des
paroles on veut effectivement que le
ministre tienne ses engagements et tout
simplement en mettant des moyens
policiers est allé demander à la police
s'ils sont suffisants pour aller faire
des patrouilles pour pouvoir sécuriser
chaque intervention de sapeurs-pompiers
la réponse est non systématiquement non
parce qu'il n'y a pas les moyens
financiers humains c'est laisser encore
on en revient toujours à la même chose
faire des économies sur meu sacrifice du
service public
c'est vrai pour les sapeurs pompiers
c'est vrai pour la police c'est vrai
pour les hôpitaux les abus commis 19
c'est vrai pour tous tout le service
public est en train de se casser la
figure et donc à chaque fois qu'un
ministre nous dit on va porter plainte
vous avez notre soutien on va tout faire
pour sécuriser derrière n'a pas le moyen
humain et il n'y a que ce bilan il n'y
en a pas 150 autres je parle pas de même
des moyens de la justice lorsqu'on
arrive à attraper ces délinquants à ces
criminels
ça c'est une autre histoire mais on
voudrait de ne pas en arriver là c'est à
dire que vous voudrez cette personne
nous allons donc pour ça il faut des
moyens policiers et on ne les a pas et
la seule réponse ces derniers mois le
gouvernement a pu lui donner ce sont des
caméras piétons et là en cas d'espèce on
voit très bien que le collègue qui s'est
fait tirer dessus la caméra piétons ne
sert à rien ne m'en porte pas au feu on
les porte que sur les interventions de
secours à personne donc la caméra
quittons ce n'est pas la solution
merci annie cat et n'hésites d'avoir été
avec mon président du syndicat national
des sapeurs pompiers professionnels
merci à vous bon courage
les sujets de désaccord entre pékin et
washington ne manquent pas à lié à
huawei bien sûr mais aussi le cas à hong
kong et en réponse à la loi sur la
sécurité nationale donald trump a signé
hier un décret mettant fin aux régimes
économiques préférentielles accordées
par son pays au territoire chinois
un décret qui prévoit également des
sanctions pékin promet des représailles
françois xavier lambert avec pierre
pissavy yvernault le bras de fer
diplomatique entre la chine et les etats
unis se durcit et c'est face à la presse
depuis la maison blanche que donald
trump annonça dernières mesures fortes
contre pékin
la fin du traitement économiques
préférentielles accordées à hong kong
aujourd'hui j'ai signé un décret mettant
fin au traitement préférentiel accordé
par les états unis hong kong hong kong
sera traitée comme la chine
pas de privilège spécial pas de
traitement économique spéciale est pas
d'exportation de technologies sensibles
en plus de cela comme vous le savez nous
mettons en place des taxes importantes
et avons mis en place des taxes très
importante sur la chine
c'est la première fois que ça arrive à
la chine cette décision de donald trump
fait suite à l'instauration par la chine
d'une loi draconienne sur la sécurité
nationale dans le territoire semi
autonome depuis plus d'un an les
manifestations parfois gigantesques se
multiplient contre le pouvoir chinois
pour le président américain pékin ne
cherche qu'à remettre en cause le
caractère semi autonome du territoire
nous avons tous observé ce qui s'est
produit la situation n'est pas bonne
leur liberté leur a été retiré leurs
droits lors ont été retirés avec hong
kong disparaît à mon avis parce qu'il ne
sera plus capable d'être compétitif dans
un marché libre beaucoup de gens vont
partir de hong kong c'est ce que je
soupçonne et nous allons faire beaucoup
plus d'affaires grâce à ça nous avons
perdu un concurrent très très sérieux
avec cette décision le président
américain souhaite porter un coup majeur
à la puissance économique de l'ex
colonie britannique
et cette annonce elle s'ajoute à
d'autres sanctions le congrès américain
a voté début juillet une loi permettant
de sanctionner des responsables qui
seraient identifiés comme ouvrant pour
restreindre les libertés hong kong
le chef de la diplomatie américaine mike
pompéo a également félicité les parties
opposées à pékin qui ont organisé des
primaires dans l'optique des élections
législatives de septembre
sur un autre plan est les etats unis ont
annoncé qu'ils refuseraient des visas à
trois hauts responsables chinois accusés
d'être impliqués dans la répression des
ouigours ce mercredi est la chine a
convoqué l'ambassadeur des états unis
pour protester contre les sanctions
annoncées par washington et promet de
riposter les affaires de hong kong sont
purement les affaires intérieures de la
chine et aucun pays étranger n'a le
droit d'intervenir
la chine est ferme pour sauvegarder sa
souveraineté et sa sécurité
maintenir la stabilité la prospérité
s'opposer à l'ingérence des forces
extérieures dans les affaires de hong
kong
le plan américain visant à entraver la
mise en oeuvre de la loi sur la sécurité
nationale de hong kong ne fonctionnera
jamais pour préserver les intérêts
légitimes la chine prendra les mesures
nécessaires et sanctionnera les
individus et entités concernées
nous exhortons les états unis à corriger
les erreurs à ne pas imposer la
soi-disant législation sur l'autonomie
de hong kong à cesser d'interférer avec
les affaires intérieures de la chine y
compris les affaires de hong kong
si les états unis persistent la chine
donnera une réponse forte
après avoir cherché à rendre la chine
responsable de la pandémie mondiale de
kovy 19è les états unis ne semblent pas
vouloir faire retomber les tensions avec
pékin et pour décrypter la situation
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude vente maison merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la fin
du traitement préférentiel accordé en
compte
quelles conséquences clairement pour ce
territoire au pas comme vient de le dire
le le journaliste que j'ai entendu tout
à l'heure ça veut dire que les produits
venant de hong kong paieront des droits
de douane en entrant sur le territoire
douanier américain
mais ça veut dire aussi que hong kong
perd dans toute sa spécificité
commercial dans le fond se rapprochera
du régime des produits qui viennent de
chine
et ça veut dire aussi que
shanghai va profiter de ce déclin de
hong kong ce déclin progressif
c'est d'ailleurs un vieil objectifs des
dirigeants chinois de faire monter
shanghai qui se trouvent dans chine mais
landes au fur et à mesure du déclin de
hong kong et là le déclin évidemment est
accéléré par l'adoption à pékin de cette
loi sur la sécurité publique qui
s'applique à hong kong et qui restreint
les libertés donc un charme est rompu
il est probable comme le dit monsieur
tron qu' un certain nombre de cadres est
en tout cas d'expatriés cherchant à
quitter hong kong
d'ailleurs le royaume uni leur a ouvert
les bras de retrouveront au canada ou en
australie peut-être c'est donc c'est
donc en effet la fin d'une époque
la transition est qu à un seul pays un
pays deux systèmes n'aura duré que 23
ans au lieu de 50 ans comme c'était
prévu dans les accords entre londres et
pékin
alors la loi prévoyant des sanctions
contre la répression dans le territoire
chinois les responsables chinois mais
aussi les banques
la police est également est-ce qu'ils
ont quelque chose à craindre
oui alors là c'est beaucoup plus sérieux
parce que autant sur le décret on peut
considérer que trump dans le fond comme
il l'a dit élimine un concurrent qui
bénéficié d' avantages commerciaux
la loi qui a été votée par le congrès à
l'unanimité d'ailleurs permis de cibler
des individus ou les institutions qui
participent à la répression en kong à
travers l'application de cette loi sur
la sécurité nationale
et ces gens et bien pourront être mis
sur une liste qui fait qu' il n'emploie
pourront plus avoir de visa pour aller
au théâtre unis qui n'emploient auront
plus avoir de compte en banque ça va
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus loin puisque
les banques et les institutions
financières qui aiderait à réduire le
degré de liberté qui s'exerçait à hong
kong seront également sanctionnés sous
l' empire de cette de cette loi donc
ceci peut faire mal au dos chinois de
pékin
combinez notamment avec l'interdiction
d'exporter vers hong kong et des
produits sensibles
ça veut dire des produits de haute
technologie dont se servait la police ou
deux pourraient servir les militaires
parce que c'était bien utile à pékin
dans la mesure où la chine populaire
fait l'objet d'un embargo sur les ventes
d'armes de la part des pays occidentaux
depuis tienanmen
alors ces tensions un peu blanche maison
entre la chine et les états unis
elles se poursuivront jusqu'à la
présidentielle américaine de novembre
selon vous elles continueront sans doute
parce que la loi qui a été votée par le
congrès était votée à l'unanimité
donc les démocrates lyon y ont concouru
donc je pense qu'en effet peut-être en
fonction du résultat des élections
présidentielles du mois de novembre
prochain
l'année prochaine il pourra y avoir de
quelques changements quelques
changements quelques inflexions
actuellement il est vrai que les états
unis ont toutes un une panoplie de
mesures anti chinoises là les sanctions
contre les gens qui sont à l'origine de
la répression contre les ouïghours ces
musulmans du nord-est de la chine
l'accusation de monsieur trump que à
propos du virus de coronavirus en la
plante systématiquement le virus chinois
avec tout ce que ça implique comme
stigmatisation et puis maintenant depuis
hier monsieur pompéo qui adoptent la
position des états d'asie du sud-est et
notamment du vietnam et des philippines
pour expliquer qu'il ne peut pas
accepter les tentatives chinoises pour
faire de la mer de chine du sud que les
vietnamiens appelle d'ailleurs la mer de
l'est
une mère chinoise un sorte de lacs
chinois et par conséquent et les etats
unis se rallie à une
sentence de la cour arbitrale de la
haine qui qui indique que en effet le
comportement chinois est contraire au
droit de la mer c'est un petit peu
paradoxal parce que les américains n'ont
jamais ratifié la convention sur le
droit de la mer
mais ça ne les empêche pas effectivement
de faire monter les enchères sur ce
sujet qui est très délicat un tiers des
échanges internationaux passe par saison
et actuellement deux porte-avions
nucléaire américain
croiser en mer de chine du sud merci
claude blanchemaison merci d'avoir été
avec nous je vous rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales
merci à vous restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
manuels macro ont pris à partie hier
dans la soirée au jardin des tuileries
par des gilets jaunes une vidéo diffusée
sur facebook témoigne de cet échange
musclé qui s'apaise peu à peu et puis
nous reviendrons sur le discours de
politique générale prononcé aujourd'hui
par jean castex devant les députés
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
les crises géostratégique c'est comme
les crises sanitaires c'est pas au
moment où on est dedans qu'il faut s'en
préoccuper
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
le président trump a déclaré à plusieurs
reprises notamment à bruxelles que
c'était aux deux européens de se prendre
en charge de dépenses et pour leur
défense eh bien je pense que la
conséquence de tout ça c'est qu'il faut
que le concept de sécurité commune en
europe avance et que nous fassions tous
un effort il faut moins de diplomatie
des déclarations et un peu plus de
diplomatie de l'action
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck fait que ça veut
dire
facile à lire ça si la comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui conteste
norouzi personnes non non c'est pas vrai
il ya des climats tous et non ce n'est
pas il y en a pas il ya des gens qui ne
sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent que
la presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat le gars plus de débats
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique
on va vers un autre est par une
catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
ses cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu
que c'était bien que difficiles qui
avait une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel de rire le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
après je crois que le groupe d'avants il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ben ça m'a
rendu plus intolérant alors par mois
elle s'était d'ailleurs je vais vous
poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde arabe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fonds pouvant remettre en cause la
pensée des groupes de pression au
pouvoir l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
active dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste fonds
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi deux de profession est
ce qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
dans le protocole n'a pas évolué de la
même manière nous avions déjà commencé à
utiliser le protocole avec les gothiques
préoccupe bien avant que le match ne
commence en effet par sénégal la
chloroquine domaniale est utilisé
pendant des décennies et des décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les sénégalais
quand j'entends de niche des ménages
il n'y a pas de signes qui m'est rendu
ce protocole voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vite va permettre à cette ré
industrialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
commercer de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail de dessin un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 15 juillet notre première
ambition ressouder la nation jean castex
a prononcé sa déclaration de politique
générale devant les députés cette après
midi
adopté à 345 voix ce soir le chômage
priorité absolue des 18 prochains mois
décentraliser davantage lutter contre
les séparatismes à l'école le premier
ministre a donc précisé la feuille de
route pour les 600 prochains jours au
taux dé nombreux thèmes abordés hier par
emmanuel macron le 14 juillet l'hommage
aux soignants l'interview du président
mais aussi la prise à partie des manuels
micron parler gilet jaune alors qu'il se
promenait avec son épouse dans les
jardins des tuileries eut été interpellé
au sujet des violences policières lors
des manifestations le chef de l'état a
fini par entamer un dialogue avec les
protestataires les incidents sans suite
en a gardé leur calme
alors le président peut-il reconquérir
cet électorat qui semble perdue ou y at
il une crise de confiance irrémédiable
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
l'inde frappée de plein fouet par le
coronavirus les autorités ont décidé de
confiner à nouveau quelques 13 millions
de personnes vivent dans des mégapoles
de bangalore et ses environs le sont
depuis hier soir bientôt suivi par les
125 millions d'habitants de l'état du
milliard si le billet virus circule dans
les villes densément peuplé le bilan
humain reste contenue dans ce pays dont
la population est jeune
[Musique]
un peu plus d'une heure de discours de
politique générale pour jean castex à
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi
objectif proposer une méthode pour
mettre en oeuvre la politique voulue par
le président de la république plan de
relance économique écologie
décentralisation aide aux étudiants ou
encore lutte contre le séparatisme à
l'école de nombreuses annonces donc ont
été faites par le premier ministre elles
ont été adoptées ce soir par 345 voix
les explications de valentin carpentier
il était attendu et a voulu se faire
entendre en une heure de discours jean
castex a détaillé la feuille de route du
gouvernement pour les prochains mois
avec plusieurs points clés
le premier ministre a notamment insisté
sur la crise sanitaire
s'il a voulu rendre hommage à son
prédécesseur edouard philippe
il a tenu également à faire comprendre
qu'un relâchement ne sera pas permis et
que pour cela de nouvelles règles avec
être mise en place
la meilleure façon de nous préparer à
une reprise possible de l'épidémie est
de renforcer nos actions de prévention
cela passe nécessairement par le
développement du port du masque et une
intensification de notre politique de
dépistage
ce que nous devons par dessus tout
éviter c'est un retour à des formes
stricte et large de confinement dont
nous connaissons désormais le coût
humain et économique la crise sanitaire
a entraîné une crise économique et pour
tenter d'y remédier jean castex a fait
plusieurs annonces
le gouvernement a notamment prévu de
consacrer 40 milliards à la
reconstruction de l'industrie de la
france afin d'éviter une trop forte
dépendance vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
extérieurs après les résultats des
municipales
la question environnementale est devenue
incontournable et le premier ministre
l'a bien compris une relance verte est
de mise et l'exécutif entend concilier
pouvoir d'achat et transition écologique
le plan de relance proposera de
mobiliser plus de 20 milliards d'euros
pour la rénovation technique des
bâtiments thermique des bâtiments pour
réduire les émissions des transports et
de nos industries pour produire une
alimentation plus local et durable pour
soutenir les technologies vertes de
demain comme les batteries pour mieux
recyclé et moins gaspiller suite à ce
discours les députés de l'opposition
n'ont pas tardé à réagir
nombre d'entre eux se sont empressés de
critiquer cette allocution et jean
castex qu'il considère comme nouvelle
effigie du maquereau nisme écoutez
c'était aussi long ennuyeux bourré de
clichés que prévu il ya une seule chose
satisfaisante puisque ça nous donne
raison séducteur idéologique c'est le
retour de haut commissariat au plan
maintenant il va falloir qu'elle
contenait donne mais au moins ils
admettent ce que nous disons depuis deux
ans et demi
cette volonté elle est naturellement
cède elle est même indispensable mais
pour valoriser les territoires il faut
des actes
on peut pas nous resservir pour la 44e
fois le développement du haut débit ou
de la téléphonie mobile ou le maintien
des petites ligues ça nous l'attendions
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière quelles
mesures concrètes
quel souffle quelles ambitions de
décentralisation je suis resté sur ma
faim
un discours qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité
mais qui a suffi pour obtenir une
majorité de soutien le premier ministre
a reçu 345 votes pour et 177 contre en
comparaison pour son premier discours de
politique générale edouard philippe
avait obtenu une large confiance de
l'assemblée nationale avec 370 vote
favorable bien plus que jean castex
emmanuel macron interpellé et filmé hier
par des gilets jaunes ont plein jardin
des tuileries à paris alors qu'il se
promenait avec son épouse un temps
distant le président ensuite décider de
dialoguer quelques instants avec eux et
j'ai les jaunes ont notamment évoqué la
bras rend cette unité à police de police
à moto remise en service pour intervenir
lors des mouvements sociaux pour mon
pause d'écouter un extrait de cet
échange entre président et certains jeux
les jeux c'est le président virait la
brave arrêté avec la mafia est arrêté
avec la brave beaucoup il à la brave du
président on parierait là mais j'irai là
bas est terrible mais je suis regardé
pourquoi vous avez remis la croix vous
avez fait ça c'est des fous de la
république vient de virer les vous avez
pouvoir arrêter que la bad dans des fûts
moi je peux faire face à tout le monde
on avoue mais pas eux mais soyez cool si
on n'en peut plus a fait six mois qu'on
est cool comme ça fait 18 mois qu'on
dirait la brave déjà je virais la pente
mais voilà pour cet échange hier soir
dans le jardin des tuileries à paris
emmanuel macron tout souriant discutant
avec un groupe de personnes se
revendiquant du mouvement des gilet
jaune le président peut-il reconquérir
cet électorat perdu ces français qui ne
votent plus ou qui votent contre lui ou
la crise de confiance et elle consomme
et c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes nous
avec un patrick mennucci ancien député
ps des bouches de rhône bonsoir patrick
mennucci merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés didier maïsto président de sud
radio auteur de passager clandestin aux
éditions le diable vauvert of rage dans
lequel à un millier vous raconter
notamment vaud marche tous les samedis
aux côtés des gilet jaune l'année
dernière bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous alors la séquence qu'on vient
de voir patrick mennucci vous l'homme
politique qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est le cauchemar de tout responsable
politique d'être ainsi interpellé en
pleine rue moi j'ai une autre idée c'est
que je crois que c'est fait à dessein
brésil la république ne peut pas
imaginer se promener un 14 juillet dans
le parc des tuileries
alors qu'il y a autour un certain nombre
de manifestations sont tombés sur des
personnes qui vont lui parler après le
niveau sonore la façon dont il s'exprime
personne ne pouvait rien savoir mais il
est à peu près certain et je vous en
parle d'expérience de jeu qui a fait
beaucoup de politiques et qui s'est
beaucoup promené sur le vieux port
quel jeu partez de chez moi pour aller à
la mairie j'étais absolument certain de
tomber sur les citoyens qu'ils allaient
me parler et donc je vois pas comment le
président de la république peut ignorer
ce genre de choses donc pour moi c'est
fait exprès c'est plutôt pas mauvais
pour lui parce que il est il démontre
que bon il est capable de parler les
gens de toutes façons en face du
président la république et à la fin
prennent une attitude plutôt
respectueuse envers plutôt correct en
tout cas je pense que c'est un bon petit
coup politique auquel on est habitué
même analyse que patrick mennucci
opération séduction qui finalement se
finit pas si mal pour un emmanuel macron
qui on l'imaginé déjà partie à la à la
reconquête de son électorat perdu les 14
juillet c'est vrai il vaut mieux jouer
au loto note reçue que les chances
de gagner calvel martingale quel sens de
l'à-propos quelle séance parfaite j'ai
de faire une interview avec des
journalistes quand même pas très
combatif bon surtout il à parler pour ne
rien dire
j'ai pas compris moi cette interview du
14 juillet à parra peut faucher l'herbe
sous le pied de son premier ministre
pour lui dire c'est moi le patron je
parle avant toi et de dire deux trois
trucs en scoop quoi bon j'avais j'ai pas
compris cette intervention donc ils
s'épient s'il sort il se balade ses
gardes du corps au togo il fait beau
hélas un petit blouson en cuir
la picarde qui va bien il interpellé
tient par départ des gilet jaune juste
au moment où on le dit faut écouter les
territoires il faut écouter les braves
gens dans la rue etc
et tiens il tombe sur un groupe de gilet
jaune ils disent aujourd'hui voilà il
faut être respectueux
il était un peu colérique au début puis
à la fin ils n'arrivent même pas à le
goût dire ils ont été séduits convaincu
complètement sous le filtre d'amour de
monsieur macro ça fait quand même je
sais patiente dans le nouveau bond
monsieur bellucci connais par coeur
ça fait partie de la vie politique
traditionnelle ont sommé en scène est
effectivement dire carrément de la
manipulation alors que patrick mennucci
n'est pas allé aussi loin il disait
voilà ils m'ignorent pas qu'on annonce
premier au jardin des tuileries il va
être interpellé mais vous vous dites en
bas alors envoyé ce sont ces nuits on
al'impression vous pensez à un coup
monté quand même pas je n'irai pas
jusque là mais je ne peux pas en tant
que journaliste connaisseurs un petit
peu de des séquences politiques et des
images de campagne
je sais vous les jeunes espèce de petit
radar je pense que tous les observateurs
qui connaissent bien
j politique en ce petit radar qui se met
en marche et killer du moule attention
c'est trop parfait et là il s'est passé
un truc ça arrive pile au bon moment
dans le discours de politique générale
du premier ministre au moment où il
change de l'équipe en nous disant que
celle qui équipe qui venait d'exercer
avec toutes les qualités que c'est pour
ça qu'ils en changent et il nous parle
de changement nouvelle direction un
nouveau virage sans que l'on sache
exactement quelle est cette direction de
ce virage puisque c'était bien avant
alors vous voyez on est dedans on est
dans le en même temps et je suis
d'accord avec monsieur l'outil c'est un
petit un petit coup politique voyez on
en parle on en parle ce soir et la
seconde la seconde second moteur le
second étage de la fusée ça va être
regardé quand même monsieur castex issus
des territoires
le président en pente raide et gilet
jaune monsieur castex avec tous sont sa
science et son don des rapports sociaux
etc
mais quand même il rehausse le pays
essaie on entre dans cette séquence là
que les media company et peut-être que
les gilet jaune qui étaient là ont ils
été les victimes consentantes ou pas ce
sont elles un peu fait piéger l'ont
imaginée avec le président que sais je
ne peux pas si c'est une manière de dire
voilà je ne veux laisser personne sur le
bas côté on se souvient de cette
séquence pendant la campagne
présidentielle où emmanuel macron avait
était pas mauvais il faut bien le dire
cette séquence marine le pen emmanuel
macron à quelques intervalles qui vont
je crois que c'était oui un poulain
lusine riehl paul et qui parle voilà à
ses ouvriers effectivement en colère
tout d'abord qui finit par lesquels mais
il sait qu'il n'est pas mauvais dans cet
exercice est effectivement c'est une
manière pour lui d'aller à la reconquête
de cet électorat qui ne s'est perdu en
tout cas pour l'instant
je crois que c'est exactement est ce que
vous décrivez je suis d'accord avec
monsieur maisto choix connaît d'accord
tous les deux on connaît
un goûter l'autre delà de la réalité
médiatique de la politique qu'ils
mangent et diriger une campagne
présidentielle donc je vois bien la
force des images
je ne peux pas imaginer je crois que
tous les observateurs que le président
république est là par hasard donc après
on ne lui a pas mis des gilet jaune sur
ce chemin mais on ne peut pas ne pas
savoir quand on marche dans le parc des
tuileries ce du jour de 14 juillet
comment rencontrer des jeunes donc
est-ce qu'il avait fui avec toute la
sécurité
non quand on connaît comment ça
fonctionne on s'aventure pas comme ça
c'est sécuriser d'abord il ya une
première équipe qui va voir ils sont
reliés porte par talkie walkie par pas
bon et cetera et cetera
c'est pas si tu as de la séance est un
peu musclé olayan rien à qui le traitent
voilà vous êtes mon employé alors je
vous propose d'écouter justement la
réaction de jean-luc mélenchon à cette
phrase de ce gilet jaune qui dit mais
vous vous êtes emmanuel macron
d'employés écouter les gens ont raison
de dire que macro et leurs employés
moi aussi je suis l'employé du peuple
français c'est avoir une conscience
républicaine de dire cela patrick même
si je voulais votre réaction là dessus
est ce qu'au final ça ne bénéficient pas
emmanuel macron voilà ce gilet jaune de
manière un peu plus que du niveau là
vous êtes mon employé on ne peut ne pas
être d'accord bien évidemment avec le
chef de l'état il n'empêche qu'il a été
élu démocratiquement est ce que c'est
une manière de parler qui est approprié
aujourd'hui où finalement vous trouvez
que voilà comme le dit jean luc
mélenchon on exprime pour reprendre les
expressions de certaines une forme de
colère saine dans les camps tome 10 à
quelques vous êtes mon employé c'est
généralement pas positif
en tout cas moi cette expression que je
j'abhorre que je n'emploierai jamais et
jean luc mélenchon a tort de justifier
ce genre d'expression parce que ce n'est
pas l'employé de la personne dont il
parle c'est juste le président de la
république qui a été élu alors s'il fait
référence à ceux de salaire oui
effectivement arrivé en partie
constituée de nos impôts enfin je veux
dire c'est pas très intéressant ce qui
me paraît intéressant mois plus tôt
c'est c'est la séquence
c'est à dire une une interview qui fut
très honnêtement de faible niveau
moi j'ai pas tout compris en l'écoutant
je vous que un peu de mal à comprendre
ce qui se disait du journaliste qui
était plutôt accommodants disons ensuite
on a cet épisode aux tuileries et puis
cette après midi on a le jean castex
je crois que c'est ça qui aujourd'hui
était important qu'est ce qui dit jean
castex
cet après midi il dit on avait un
désaccord avec la droite dans ce pays
c'est la question de la sécurité par
contre sur l'économie grosso modo on est
d'accord et donc ils essayent d'en
rajouter sur la question de la sécurité
est comme ça ils vont arriver à
phagocyter le candidat qui les inquiète
qui pourrait les inquiéter plus d'un but
il y aura le candidat peut-être de la
gauche et des écologistes qui posera un
problème c'est le candidat de la droite
donc nous sommes dans une stratégie qui
va durer quelques mois qui consiste à ne
pas permettre à xavier bertrand
ouah un autre candidat issu des
républicains d'émerger donc on envoie un
premier ministre comme jean castex qui
vient du parti républicain qui très
honnêtement un discours cet après midi
qui est un discours de droite assez
simple et qui prend en compte la
situation la nécessité de la de la
relance économique il ya deux choses
dans le discours de jean castex après
midi il ya la relance ayant la sécurité
et
en plus je crois qu'il y a réellement
message pour moi c'est plutôt positif
il y a réellement la volonté de
d'éclairer la question de la laïcité
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un alignement des
ministres qui est plus clair qu'avec le
gouvernement précédent si on prend blank
r6 en bande darmanin et si on pense
castex on est sur des jeunes qui sont
d'accord sur la laïcité c'est pour ça à
mon avis qu'on annonce la loi contre le
séparatisme et enfin peut-être enfin
peut-être là le discours du président la
république quand nous avons vu depuis
trois ans et demi sur la laïcité
donc je pense que c'est ça qui se passe
cet après midi c'est la volonté de faire
en sorte que ne puisse pas émerger un
candidat de la droite après le président
a pu lui qui se dit et je verrai pour la
gauche
un peu plus tard on va d'ailleurs je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait voilà
pas par infographie de ce discours de
jean castex qui en quelque sorte répond
au gilet jaune puisque c'était notre
postulat je sais pour la côtoyer tous
les jours qu'il existe une france qui ne
dit rien mais qui n'en pensent pas moins
une france du bon sens et de la raison
une france que nous devons aujourd'hui
écoutés et mieux considérés alors là
didier maïsto effectivement comme le
souligne et patrick mennucci voilà on
est vraiment cette france qu'on écoute
pas qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque du marketing du marketing
je suis je suis ce qui est tout à fait à
l'analyse que vient de faire patrick
mennucci je rajouterais une pincée de
verre aussi nous allons nous annonce que
pour relancer le pays
on va faire du vélo et de la rénovation
thermique est très bien pourquoi pas un
pour tous tous à vélo vous allez voir
dans les campagnes dans la ruralité
comment les gens vont vous erroné quand
vous avez là il n'y a pas ce qu'il y'a
qu'à paris à lyon à marseille et à
bordeaux qu'on fait du vélo c'est tout
un bon je ferme la parenthèse mais
effectivement on est on est dans
du marketing on est en aidant du
marketing et on voit qu'il a bien bloqué
d'ailleurs il y avait déjà fait avec
edouard philippe alors là il en rajoute
une petite louche avec monsieur castex
qui est compatible qui est malléable
mais qui a l'apparence comme ça d'être
un peu rugueuse avec un accent qu'il
faut authentique et toutes les deux
phrases il pourrait y prononce le mot
territoire c'est là aussi c'est
complètement obscur parce qu'on nous dit
qu'on va aller vers une nouvelle étape
de décentralisation et il nous parle
surtout de déconcentration en redonnant
du pouvoir au département faisant
exploser probablement la fonction
publique territoriale qui a déjà explosé
avec une catastrophe qui nous amenait
avec tous ces fonctionnaires et ne
fonctionne pas qu'ils sont des
administratifs jeu quand je vois les ars
et toutes les catastrophes française et
tous et ses fromages qu'on empile les
uns sur les autres
alors il faut savoir soit c'est en une
république française avec l territoire
bien compris et accepté soit on donne le
pouvoir aux régions ont fait des lander
soit on revient un peu à une conception
plus traditionnels issus de napoléon et
on dit la france et des départements
mais tout à la fois quand on voit
aujourd'hui la situation de notre
économie relancée comme ça deux des
défauts emplois en dix ans le lycée
hâtive dans les territoires où il s'est
attiré des hommes dans les territoires
mais sont pas les fonctionnaires qui
vont libérer les énergies toutes ces
formules creuses que j'ai encore entendu
mais ça fait trente ans que je les
entends intrigue mais aussi justement
sur ces territoires
ce droit à la différenciation d'ailleurs
des territoires qui sera consacré dans
une loi organique
ça vous parle je moi moi j'avais cru
comprendre
d'un certain nombre d'interventions du
président la république du premier
ministre il ya une semaine qu'on allait
s'orienter vers en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a dit à la réunion des dés de
l'association des régions de france qui
présidait paronnaud muselier souvenez
vous il ya une quinzaine de jours renaud
muselier va voir le président de la
république il y à une colle fait une
réunion où mme avec l'ensemble des
présidents de région et on annonce à ce
moment là que le président république va
repousser les élections régionales pour
faire une loi de décentralisation
nouvelle donner plus de pouvoir aux
régions
ça a disparu cc s'est passé dans un trou
je ne sais absolument pas lequel
aujourd'hui on nous parle de la fonction
publique départementale
mais la fonction publique départementale
cette exclusion ça n'existe pas il
existe la fonction publique territoriale
et la fonction publique territoriale
s'est majoritairement les municipalités
n'ont pas les départements donc je
n'arrive pas bien comprendre même dans
les monts qui sont employées ce qu'on
veut dire en réalité je crois qu'on veut
noyer le poisson médias quoi ça me fait
penser
c'est la question que vous vous posez à
monsieur maïs travers moi en début et en
fin de votre intervention
moi ça me fait penser un peu aux
pompidolisme
monsieur le premier ministre et il l'a
démons et est-ce que derrière il y aura
au moins les constructions dont avait
été capable
le premier ministre georges combes îlots
moi je pense surtout qu'ils manquent des
choses de ce discours est ce qu'il ya un
référendum sur l'article 1 de la
constitution concernant l'environnement
ça nous a été annoncé mais là on est
dans un discours à l'assemblée nationale
on n'en parle plus est ce qu'il y à une
réforme du parquet on a vu que on avait
un premier on avait un ministre un garde
des sceaux qui s'est exprimé en disant
je viens parce que je vais faire une
réforme du parquet sous-entendu on va
aller vers l'indépendance accrues des
magistrats
le premier ministre n'en dit pas un mot
or c'est un élément essentiel de la
république de la façon dont on vit j'ai
vu il ya quelques jours que on dit on
nous parle de la proportionnelle c'est
une pression qui est faite par françois
bayrou et le modem éternellement sur le
président république il n'y a pas un mot
est ce qu'on aurait pu s'attendre quand
même parce que peut-être que jean castex
à force de regarder les territoires ils
regardent plus l'europe mais il ya quand
même des déclarations hier et avant-hier
d'angéla merkel y compris du président
polonais lui qui pourtant n'est pas un
européen convaincu du danemark de
l'italie qui parle de la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui permettrait
de financer 500 milliards de
500 milliards d'euros et de permettre de
rajouter ça à la relance
pas un mot du premier ministre devant
l'assemblée nationale
or c'est quand même une déclaration delà
de la chancelière acquis kern tout à
fait importante et nouvelles donc voilà
je suis un peu je suis un peu stupéfait
de la façon dont ça se passe parce qu'il
ya un seul but en réalité c'est celui de
2,2 marabouté la droite parce que la
gauche là il n'y a rien pour la gauche
de ce discours ou pas grand-chose maisto
l'a dit un peu des vélos moment là mais
c'est surtout pour la droite que c'est
fait et pour empêcher l'émergence d'un
candidat type bertrand à l'élection
présidentielle merci en tout cas à tous
les deux patrick mennucci didier maïsto
d'avoir été avec nous pour décrypter
l'actualité la séquence emmanuel macron
echiejile jaune est évidemment
l'actualité de jours avec ce discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
qui a été adoptée je vous le rappelle
avec 345 voix dans l'hémicycle ce soir
merci à tous les deux
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons dur confinement en 1 13
million de personnes sont concernées à
bang leader notamment et près de 125
millions dans l'état du bihar
[Musique]
pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr la banque ne gagne
pas d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche deux mois de non
consommation mondiale et les plus gros
groupe s'arrête et 10
on n'a pas de trésorerie c'est un modèle
assez extraordinaire à la banque c'est à
dire que jusqu'à maintenant c'était
privatisation des gains et mutualisation
des perfs donc en fait c'est fâcheux
gagne pile tu perds ont créé une
économie qui l'a zéro valeur
statistiquement vous aurez une banque en
europe une banque majeur en europe qui
sautera
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien pour rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
ses cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu
que c'était bien que difficiles qui
avait une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mines de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
et ben ça m'a rendu plus intolérant
alors par mois elle s'est d'ailleurs
opposée justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde à man
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent nos
résidents de six personnes
non non c'est pas vrai il ya des climats
tous et non ce n'est pas il y en a pas
il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
le gars plus de débats aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un autre est
par une catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre c'est très
industrialisé à sion cela ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail de dessin un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 21h30 heure
française en direct sur rt france
confinement en inde à 13 millions de
personnes vivantes à bangalore et 125
millions de l'état du billard ce pays
très peuplés peine à freiner la
propagation du virus et spécialistes
estiment même que le pic de l'épidémie
n'est toujours pas atteint wang bennani
ces dernières heures les files
d'attentes se multiplient à bangalore
capitale de l'état de karnataka dans le
sud de l'inde
stress peur appréhension les 13 millions
d'habitants de cette région se prépare à
nouveau confinement
pendant toute la semaine prochaine nous
ne pourrons pas sortir
nous sommes donc venus ici pour acheter
des produits alimentaires nous sommes en
train de nous préparer parce que sinon
nous aurions fait ça un peu plus tard
mais maintenant que ça entre en vigueur
nous sommes obligés de venir chercher
des provisions une semaine donc de
confinement actée dès ce mardi soir par
les autorités locales
transports publics à l'arrêt seuls les
services et commerces et son ciel
maintenu à vrai coup dur pour les
patrons et salariés de bangalore
mégalopole considéré comme le siège de
la haute technologie indienne ici à
brigade rod de nombreux magasins ont
fermé
pas seulement du fait du coc vide mais
aussi à cause de la situation économique
du pays
en tout près de 25 magasins ont fermé il
n'y a pas de travail à cause du
coronavirus avant je travaillais à la
maison mais depuis la fête du nouvel an
indien il n'y a plus du tout travail de
ci de là je faisais un peu de couture
maintenant pour une semaine de plus il
impose de faire mais je n'ai plus
d'activités ici c'est pour cela que je
retourne dans mon village natal
l'inde géant aux pieds d'argile 200
mille nouveaux cas sont apparus en neuf
jours
et face à cette augmentation une
douzaine d'états ont décidé de prolonger
le confinement
une à deux semaines jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet dans les bidonvilles ou
encore dans les centres urbains le
personnel médical est certes présent
mais surtout des plus préoccupé c'est
vraiment une situation difficile en
réalité nous avons besoin de deux à
trois fois plus d'infirmières qu'en
temps ordinaire
s'il nous en faut 100 en temps ordinaire
il nous en faut 250 à 300 actuellement
parce que les horaires de travail sont
plus courts et qu'après une semaine
d'isolement est imposée alors que le
seuil symbolique du million de personnes
infectées pourraient être franchis dans
les prochains jours
le vaste et déshéritées état du billard
se prépare à voir ses 125 millions
d'habitants confinés pour deux semaines
dès ce jeudi et pour en parler nous
sommes avec claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales bonsoir
toge blanche maison
leur confinement en inde est ce le signe
que la situation sanitaire s'aggrave
oui mais ça s'aggrave temporairement en
effet on va en approche du seuil de 1
million de personnes contaminées est
effectivement avec un nombre de morts
qui est de l'ordre de 25 mille morts ce
qui fait beaucoup bien sûr en valeur
absolue beaucoup moins si on rapporte à
la population non body premier ministre
avait décidé le 22 mars de confiner
complètement le pays
et puis il a des confiné deux mois plus
tard mais essentiellement pour des
raisons économiques pour que l'activité
puisse reprendre
mais en inde la santé dépend des états
et pas de la fédération donc les chief
minister les responsables des états
peuvent prendre des mesures plus
strictes que ce que recommande ou ce que
décide le centre ce que les sites des
lits et c'est le cas en effet hier à
bengalore il a été décidé de re confiner
la mégapole qui fait 13 millions
d'habitants de la même façon le chief
minister de bhubaneswar au bia a décidé
de re confiné l'ensemble de l'état 125
millions d'habitants et d'autres
d'autres chief minister dans d'autres
états ont décidé de prolonger
pour jusqu'à la fin du mois le
confinement donc on a une sorte de
résurgence de la de la pandémie avec
néanmoins la limite qui a encore une
fois que si on rapporte à chaque fois
les chiffres en valeur absolue à la
population qui je vous rappel de 1
milliard 350 millions on s'aperçoit que
la population affectée est d'environ 0
75 % de la population totale ce qui est
très faible par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu en occident alors quelles
conséquences pour l'économie indienne
grave bien sûr à court terme mais
l'économie indienne est très souple et
flexible et s'en remettra alors le cas
de bangalore est particulier puisque
comme on l'a dit dans votre sujet c'est
là une sorte de silicon valley indienne
c'est là que se concentre la haute
technologie indienne est également les
entreprises de services informatiques
avec notamment la célèbre entreprise
infosys dans ce secteur je pense qu'un
certain nombre de gens pourront faire du
télétravail
mais c'est grave en effet que une
mégapole comme bague alors soit confiné
confiné plus directement pendant deux
semaines le billard c'est différent
parce que le billard est un état pauvre
et qui exporte sa main d'oeuvre dans les
autres états donc quand maudit a décrété
un confinement brutale et très générale
à la fin du mois de mars est bien un
grand nombre de travailleurs qui venait
du billard et qui se trouvait à bombay à
delhi ou ailleurs se sont retrouvés du
jour au lendemain sans aucune ressource
et sans la possibilité de payer le
moindre loyers non plus par conséquent
ils ont voulu prendre la route pour
rentrer chez eux ou billard ou ailleurs
et évidemment ils n'ont pas pu parce que
tous les services de transports avait
été également stoppé quelques heures
après l annonce du premier ministre
alors c'est une grande catastrophe
humanitaire qui s'est déroulé et
effectivement lorsque ces personnes sont
arrivés au billard certaines d'entre
elles étaient sans doute porteuses du
virus ayant contaminé leur famille ou
leurs proches
donc effectivement bien que encore une
fois la situation soit dramatique avec
des ne déchiffre dénombre en valeur
absolue qui sont élevés en valeur
relative par rapport au total de la
population
c'est moins grave que dans les pays
occidentaux les économies reprendra les
reprendra notamment parce que parce que
une grande partie de l'économie est
informel et que 80% des emplois en inde
dépendent du secteur informel c'est donc
une grande souplesse et la question
qu'on peut se poser comme blanchemaison
est-ce que cela a des conséquences sur
la popularité du premier ministre n'a un
drame audi est bien très curieusement
c'est peut-être un le plus étonnant
l'histoire c'est que en effet ça ne
semble pas avoir eu de graves
conséquences sur la popularité de maudit
il y a deux semaines un sondage donnait
un taux de popularité de 75% ce que
beaucoup de dirigeants dans les pays
occidentaux pourraient pourraient lui
envier
que ce soit aux états unis que ce soit
hors grande bretagne ou en france
alors comment comment s'y est il pris
dans le fond alors que sa gestion de la
pandémie a été assez erratique
il faut bien dire il a confiné trop tard
il a des conflits nés trop tôt et comme
l'essentiel des compétences et dans les
états effectivement de toute façon il
n'y a pas grand chose alors il a
justement utiliser cet argument en
donnant des directives au chief minister
d'état mais qui les respecte et où ne le
respectaient pas est en réalité
prenez une marche de précaution et puis
il a en effet une image très
particulières en inde et l'image du
protecteur de la population
en plus c'est quelqu'un qui a une vie
assez assez frugal pour ne pas dire
ascétique lui n'est pas suspect de la
moindre corruption qui est rarissime
dans le personnel politique indien et
par conséquent la population considère
qu'il est l'homme qui pourra conduire
à retrouver la puissance ou en tout cas
les fastes d'antan alors façon qu vide
où on et l'inde
on en parle souvent dans la course au
vaccin alors vous savez que l'un d'eux
est la plus grande pharmacie du monde
c'est là où on fabrique le plus de
médicaments génériques
et c'est là où on fabrique également la
moitié des vaccins toutes maladies
confondues dans le monde
donc bien sûr il ya des laboratoires de
recherche qui actuellement comme dans
beaucoup d'autres pays du monde
recherche alors on ne sait pas lesquels
trouveront en premier si ce seront les
américains les européens les français
les suisses les britanniques mais en
tout cas ce que l'on sait c'est
lorsqu'on aura trouvé la formule d'un
vaccin peut-être on en trouvera
plusieurs concurrentes l'inde à la
capacité industrielle de produire une
très grande quantité des millions et des
millions de vaccins en très peu de temps
elle a cette capacité industrielle et ça
sera probablement très utile pour
pouvoir produire les bâtir les vaccins
en nombre suffisant et un coût qui soit
acceptable
même dans les pays en voie de
développement merci claude blanchemaison
pour cette analyse est justement
continue de parler de ce vaccin
évidemment que tout le monde cherche un
contre le coronavirus et l'espoir d'en
trouver un se renforce aux états unis
notamment
l'entreprise de biotechnologie moderne a
réussi à générer un niveau élevé
d'anticorps chez les participants à son
essai le vaccin va donc entré dans la
dernière phase de son essai clinique le
27 juillet clément hospital ce sont des
résultats encourageants
le vaccin expérimental a déclenché la
production d'un niveau élevé d'anticorps
contre le colis de 19 chez les
participants c'est ce qu'a permis
d'observer la première phase de l'essai
du groupe américain moderna le vaccin
entre donc dans la phase finale de son
essai clinique pour tester son
efficacité dans des conditions réelles
c'est une façon prudente et progressive
de faire les choses tout d'abord avec un
petit groupe de jeunes personnes
ensuite vous l'élargisse et aux
personnes plus âgées
ce que cela a très bien fonctionné dans
le groupe des plus jeunes il faudra voir
comment les personnes plus âgées
réagissent nous savons qu'ils ne
réagissent généralement pas aussi bien
au bac 5 et les plus jeunes c'est un
aspect que nous examinerons très
attentivement une étape déterminante qui
sera réalisé avec la participation de 30
mille américains
la moitié d'entre eux recevront une dose
de 100 microgrammes du vaccin
les autres se verront injecter un
placebo les chercheurs suivront ensuite
les patients durant deux ans pour
déterminer s'ils sont protégés contre le
coc vie 19 une bonne nouvelle selon
anthony fauci
le plus aux experts en maladies
infectieuses de l'administration
américaine
si votre vaccin peut apporter une
réaction comparable à une infection
naturel
c'est une victoire c'est pourquoi nous
sommes très satisfaits des résultats
si la dose retenu pour les essais
s'annonce efficace moderna prévoit de
produire 500 millions de doses par an le
groupe américain se prépare à produire à
plus grande échelle jusqu'à 1 milliard
d'unités moderna n'est pas la seule
entreprise lancée dans une course contre
la montre pour trouver un vaccin
la compagnie chinoise sinovac biotech en
seraient à un stade avancé de ses
recherches en russie le centre de
recherche en épidémiologie et
microbiologie de moscou a annoncé avoir
achevé les essais cliniques d'un futur
vaccin
mais pour le moment aucune donnée n'a
été rendue publique
et pour en parler nous sommes avec the
man guérin et immunologiste du collectif
laissons les médecins à prescrire
bonsoir violaine guérin merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à leur phase finale a on vient de longs
temps de ces essais cliniques pour
trouver un vaccin pour cette société
américaine alors pour le commun des
mortels évidemment c'est difficile de
comprendre car on nous dit qu'un un
vaccin ce ne sera pas au minimum avant
2021 voir bien après alors à quel délai
peut-on s'attendre clairement alors
effectivement c'est surprenant puisque
normalement on prend du temps pour
développer des médicaments et
l'annoncent 2
modern ans était étonnante parce qu'en
fait ils ont bouclé ce qu'on appelle la
phase 1 qui est une phase où on analyse
la tolérance surtout et manifestement il
saute allègrement la phase 2 qui est une
phase de recherche de doses puis ce
qu'ils annoncent a priori non quand même
débuté le 29 mai mais ils débutent leur
phase iii à grande échelle avant que
d'avoir testé et obtenu les résultats de
notre recherche de doses qui devait
tester 50 microgrammes versus 100
microgrammes et là ils partent en phase
iii sur 100 microgrammes
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait mais moqué
du tout dans un plan de même si on est
en urgence et autres ce d'autant plus
qu'on a des effets secondaires sur les
patients qui ont été traités en phase 1
et en particulier fait 2 200
microgrammes
donc ça veut dire quoi concrètement que
il ya une forme de tolérance de la part
des autorités américaines parce que
voilà pour prendre notre exemple
français on sait à quel point tout cela
est contrôlé avec des procédures très
strictes on l'a vu pendant toute cette
crise du coronavirus avec les
médicaments ça veut dire que ce n'est
pas la même chose clairement aux états
unis il faut pas dire que en europe on
sait bien non plus hein et en france non
plus parce que là on vient de
s'apercevoir aujourd'hui qu'on nous
donne les documents de l' autorisation
temporaire d'utilisation du rem désir et
on apprend que des patients depuis
janvier on a été traités avec ce
médicament alors que normalement il y
aurait dû avoir une autorisation
d'utilisation
donc on peut pas dire que
yep que aux états unis que les choses ne
se passent pas bien là c'est sûr qu'on
est dans un état de crise avec une
pandémie qui fait peur à tout le monde
donc on veut aller vite mais il faut pas
aller trop vite puisque là on va faire
cette phase iii avec la dose qui est qui
donnait le plus d'effets indésirables
donc pour les patients c'est pas c'est
pas une bonne chose si vous regardez des
documents concernant leur phase 2 il
devait avoir le rapport de l'étude en
août devine 2021 donc ça veut dire qu'on
aurait dû débuter la phase iii tel ce
moment là alors justement la phase iii
on en parle 1 30 mille volontaires selon
l' agence de presse reuters aucun des
volontaires n'a ressenti d'effets
secondaires importants ça veut dire que
d'une certaine manière la communication
au grand public est un peu tronqué
puisque quand on vous écoute on se rend
compte qu'elle voilà d'autres phases et
notamment cette phase 2 qui a été un
petit peu voilà escamoté qui est
pourtant très importante
ça veut dire qu'on ne donne pas les
clefs au grand public pour comprendre et
bien appréhender la situation est là
vous avez vous communiquer sur ce qui a
été communiqué à la presse surtout dans
le dossier de presse mais si vous lisez
l'étude des résultats qui ont été
publiés dans le new england journal of
medicine
on vous avait quand même la liste des
événements indésirables est en phase 1
on note des fêtes de la fatigue des
frissons des maux de tête des douleurs
musculaires
donc si c'est vacciner pour faire un
petit caux vie dont un coup c'est
peut-être pas ce n'est peut-être pas
idéal et de ce que j'ai cru comprendre
dans ce que j'ai lu c'est que cela la
dose de 100 microgrammes à quasiment
toutes les personnes qui ont été testées
ont eu des événements indésirables
justement quand on parle voilà aux
français dans la rue tout bêtement on se
rend compte qu'il ya beaucoup de
défiance notamment évidemment compte de
l'intérêt financier que ça représente
beaucoup de français n'irai pas se faire
vacciner si un vaccin sortez vous
comprenez précisément cette cette
défiance de la part de la population
envers voilà tout simplement les
autorités ans qu'ils n'ont pas confiance
et
et accessoirement un vaccin il sortait
la crise ducobu d'ajustement mis en
évidence des tas de dysfonctionnements
je vous donne un autre exemple encore
qui nous est apparu aujourd'hui en
france donc il ya cette problématique
qu'on va trop vite pour des raisons
financières donc c'est sûr qu'un vaccin
pourrait être intéressant mais il faut
pas qu'ils créent plus de dégâts que la
maladie elle-même
et puis en france bon nous savons que le
protocole préconisée par le professeur
raoul est temps que 79 des trains
destine ou azithromycine seul comme nous
l'avons également testé dans notre
collectif fonctionne très bien
donc c'est vrai que pour les français on
peut avoir aussi l'idée de se soigner
tout ça me prendrait pathologie donc
c'est vrai que c'est tout à fait
compréhensible que comme l'est la
population soit perdue je vais vous dire
il ya même des médecins qui seront
perdus le même et beaucoup de monde soit
voilà ont du mal à comprendre
tous ces enjeux et tout ce qui se passe
emmanuel macron en bas du lait les aider
à y voir plus clair parce que président
lui même affirmé hier aux journalistes
qu en cas de co vide il ne prendrait pas
de deux chloroquine bon mais qu'il
suivrait quand même l'avis de ses
médecins
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
réponse parce que autant voilà les la
communication sur les vaccins est très
rassurante autant en france il ya cette
méfiance clair pour l'hydro xi
chloroquine écoutez il ya des études qui
sortent au fur à mesure là vous aviez un
reportage sur l'inde avant que de me
prendre à l'antenne je trouve ça
extrêmement intéressant parce que le
vous dites vous signaliez que les
vingt-cinq mille morts en inde pour une
population d'1 milliard 350 millions il
faut savoir qu'ils ont justement
l'utiliser en tout cas dans certaines
provinces où le protocole choix la
chloroquine 3d roxy coquine et qu'ils
ont aussi des études en
chimioprophylaxie c'est à dire en
prévention avec les drogues site eurokin
qui ont été significatives et
intéressante
donc c'est le président de la république
qui nous dit qu' il prend pas d'option
il laisse les scientifiques
décidée en disant qu'il ne prendrait pas
part de doc le deed roxy chloroquine
c'est déjà une position
on voit bien qu'au niveau du
gouvernement français avec les
différences d'arrêté qui lie à lui
empêchant la liberté prescrire des
médecins il ya un vrai problème
politique aux scientifiques qu'il faut
continuer d'éclaircir en tout cas voilà
on parle beaucoup de cette deuxième
vague
les médecins alertent évidemment
conséquence le gouvernement lui prend
des mesures le port du masque va être
certainement généralisé le 1er août
pourquoi pas a dit emmanuel macron
quelle est votre réaction
beaucoup ont critiqué cette date du 1er
août se demandant pourquoi le 1er août
vous en faites partie
moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter de faire
peur aux français
on est sur une feinte de d'épidémie et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de légitimité à
mon sens de continuer à être après a
préconisé des émeutes alors qu'on ne les
a pas préconisé au moment où il était
vraiment utile mois connaissant un petit
peu cesser ces évolutions
de ces virus c'est évolution saisonnière
je pense qu'il faudra être prudent
plutôt mois d'octobre au mois de
novembre parce que mon à priori là on a
l'information probablement que en france
les premiers cas ont lieu peut-être au
moins de novembre à colmar
là où il y avait beaucoup de visiteurs
chinois donc ça peut nous donner un
petit peu une idée de quand une nouvelle
épidémie saisonnière pourrait débuter
mais là je pense qu'il faut laisser les
français tranquilles il ya des
traitements qui existe et arrêter de
leur faire peur parce que l'on teste
énormément en ce moment parce qu'on on a
plein de textes qui vont se terminer
bientôt donc il faut les utiliser et bon
c'est quand on regarde les courbes
d'entrée en réanimation autres elles
sont activement par l'inquiétante donc
qu'on ait des tests qu'ils soient
positifs
c'est comme si on testait par le passé
d'aidé au mois de juillet des gens avec
le viage de la grippe il ya toujours
quelques virus qui traîne ce d'autant
plus que les gens ont été confinés et
maintenant on a une des populations
qu'ils aient qui se mélange il ya des
gens qui voyagent qui voyagent en
particulier dans des régions où il n'y
avait pas eu de patients infectés
quasiment dont tout ce qui est en train
de se passer est normal et à mon sens
pas inquiétants mais les clusters
pardonnez moi parce que c'est c'est vrai
que votre voix dissonantes par rapport à
tout ce qu'on voit sur les plateaux télé
actuellement tous ces clusters notamment
mayenne ça ne vous inquiète pas plus que
cela vous au gymnase où le mot cluster
pardonnez moi non mais vous avez raison
de l'employé parce que c'est ça qu'il
est temps pour essayer ça fait
scientifique entre guillemets bon pour
moi ça fait partie un petit peu dvd
manipulation quand on entend pour faire
peur aux gens
si vous testez tout le monde a tenté
avec n'importe quel test vous allez
forcément avoir des tests positifs vous
tester sur la rubéole vous tester sur la
varicelle vous testez vous êtes si on
conteste tout le monde
on va avoir des tests positifs donc les
fameux cluster entre guillemets c'est
sont des zones où il ya une personne qui
qui a été infecté et qui lui va
peut-être en affecter quelques-unes mais
on a vu en plus ce que c'est c'est
cluster ça veut pas dire que quand on a
un test positif on va être gravement
malade non plus un puisque on rappelle
quand même que cette pathologie elle et
elle n'est pas elle est plutôt bénigne
dans l'ensemble donc ce qui est
important c'est de voir comment aussi
ces gens évoluent mais on voit pas
d'entrer en réanimation qui flambent on
n'a pas de sens pour moi il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude il faut juste que les gens
soient respectueux je pense que je
connais beaucoup appris dans cette
épidémie c'est de rappeler l'importance
de se laver les mains d'une bonne
hygiène ça c'est très important
mais voilà il faut se rappeler qu'on a
on a montré aux français que les cas
hospitalisés que les cas graves et s'est
passé pas de femmes images de cette
épidémie
donc oui elle des cadres à mais pourquoi
aussi on a eu du mal à digérer c'est
parce qu'il y avait des problèmes dans
spitalier parce qu'on a fermé des lits
parce que tout s'est concentré en un
temps extrêmement court parce qu'on n'a
pas voulu utiliser des traitements qui
fonctionnait parce qu'on n'a pas utilisé
la compétence des médecins généralistes
puisqu'on a dit aux patients de ne pas
contacter leur généraliste de rester à
la maison de ne pas être soigné donc
is c'est toute cette pratique et pose
des problèmes merci beaucoup avait l'air
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rtl
france merci à vous hélas avec nous
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
point complet sur l'actualité ce sera à
22h heure française
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
les crises géostratégique c'est comme
les crises sanitaires c'est pas au
moment où on est dedans qu'il faut s'en
préoccuper
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
le président trump a déclaré à plusieurs
reprises notamment à bruxelles que
c'était aux deux européennes se prendre
en charge de dépenses et pour leur
défense eh bien je pense que la
conséquence de tout ça c'est il faut que
le concept de sécurité commune en europe
avance et que nous fassions tous un
effort il faut moins de diplomatie des
déclarations et un peu plus de
diplomatie de l'action
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rencontre que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
vous maintenez le traitement à base
d'hydroquinone rockin